dan Senora has spent several years
working on the hill and in the White
House he was a senior adviser to Mitt
Romney and Paul Ryan in the 2012
presidential campaign good morning good
morning charlie
look at these low ratings look at the
deepening probe how much of a
distraction is is this for the president
trying to run in the country well it's
an enormous distraction because in any
White House there's obviously a lot of
tension when you're trying to get things
done in your first year you try to keep
your staff cohesive this is a White
House staffer there already is a lot of
infighting then you layer on to that
political pressure low approval ratings
and then a legal and investigation so
staff members are lawyering up there's
already you know distrust builds among
them no one knows who's cooperating with
investigators and who's not so it it
makes a difficult governing environment
even more difficult and as all this
happens they try to pass so the Senate
tries to pass a health care bill that
has been delayed now because what's
happening with Senator McCain the
conventional wisdom is that a delay is
bad will hurt chances is that true yeah
I look I spoke to a number of
legislators over the last 10 days and
the sense was one of the big challenges
they're having is the whole debate over
health care reform is an insurer
Republican debate right the moderates
are trying to get the moderates on board
they're trying to keep the placate the
conservatives people like Ted Cruz
trying to figure out what to do about
Rand Paul in the trouble he's causing
they're not making a public case
nationally it's all intra right and so
the long and the longer this takes the
more of this infighting you have and
more you have corralling people and
you're not making the case of the public
and when you combine that with these low
approval ratings for the president whose
name Walton ultimately be attached to
the health care bill it makes it tougher
and right now in Paul and Collins are
almost definite noes and not as no third
Republican senator wants to be the one
to say I was a third one right right
right but there's about five that are
sort of hanging in the balance I think
look Mitch McConnell is a master
parliamentarian strategist I mean if
anyone could pull a rabbit out of a hat
it's him I've seen him do it
a number of times over several a couple
of decades but this is this is this is a
really tough situation because time is
not their friend here because there's no
one out there making the public case for
the bill including the president when
when President Obama was making the case
for Obama care who's doing speeches he's
doing town hall meetings he's been press
conferences news doing in
there's none of that going on here it
may seem to prefer president Trump
staying out of it at this point but a
lot of the pressure that these senators
are facing is coming from their own
governor's there was a meeting of
governor's in Rhode Island over the
weekend and we know that the
administration dispatched a few of its
members including HHS secretary Price
and they were trying to talk down the
CBO and and dissuade them from really
focusing on that number is that a smart
tactic when we do get a Seabee I don't
think they've much of a choice and they
do have some good facts on their side
the CBO wildly you know miscalculated
the impact of Obamacare so there's not
without precedent and and what P CBO is
focusing on is the number of people that
will be left uninsured and I think
Republicans have a good explanation for
that so I'm not that worried about about
the CBO and I think the Republicans
should also be talking about they should
they should do everything they can to
get health care reform done but if it
doesn't get done they need to pivot
quickly the tax reform because I do
think that is winnable and you're
already just last night you're starting
to see that the White House is is
getting ready for tax reform regardless
of what happens with health care reform
they're gonna move quickly the tax
reform so they can at least get some
legislative win in before the end of the
year of course you gotta focus on the
debt ceiling and a lot on their plate
assembly which will really kick in in
September
yeah great to see could be with you guys